on va passer à l'hyper view suivante est
la dernière interview de la soirée c'est
celle de erwann menthéour ce cycliste
qui a écrit un livre qui marche très
très bien qui s'appelle secret défonce
mais nous accueillons m alors à roanne
est ce que vous allez chanter le joli
chapeau deux zozos nom avant attendre la
fin quand même pour l'entente ensuite on
m'avait dit que l'émission sérieux même
on m'avait dit le service public tu
verras c'est bon alors erwann menthéour
vous avez écrit un livre qui s'appelle
secret défonce un jeune à bon jeu de
mots dirait maître capello c'est publié
chez lattès vous avez décidé d'écrire ce
livre quand vous avez rendu visite
un de vos anciens coéquipiers qui
avaient un cancer des testicules pour
vous dire en face à ses potes ça c'est
pas décider exactement là ouais enfin ça
a aidé à votre descendance est trop
chaud connu ce livre s'est vendu en
quatre semaines à 80 mille exemplaires
donc c'est pour dire quelque chose dans
le bouquin parce que vous n'êtes pas un
auteur très connu il faut bien le dire
beaucoup moins connu de bernard henri
lévy ouais bah je peux dire en même
temps votre livre se vend à 80 mille
exemplaires en quatre semaines 1 c'est
numéro un des ventes
il faut dire qu'il ya de la coque à
l'intérieur il ya pas mal de dôme de
laon et il ya eu des points comme c'est
fait c'est très étonnant c'est ce qui
vous arrive et des pointes à 6000
exemplaires par jour
oui non mais j'en ai bien conscience
j'en avais confiance était comment après
son passage dans l'émission à france
inter
donc est ce que l'équipe en a parlé de
votre bouquin est ce que le journal
l'équipe en a parlé oui si c'est oui ils
en ont parlé parce que
ils ont eu peur que le canard en parle
avant avant tout parce qu'il voulait pas
réagir là-dessus et donc ils ont
interprété mon comportement en disant
que j'étais mégalo le mytho que j'avais
jamais été un bon coureur en fait que
j'étais le tocard accès erwann menthéour
qui a inventé le dopage en fait d'accord
ouais mais en même temps c'est un peu
con principe qui vous aiment pas trop
parce que le groupe qui possède le
journal l'équipe et possède le tour de
france 0 pas mourir alors vous dites
sales cependant ce bouquin je me suis
mis à poil pour qu'on découvre les
coulisses du cyclisme et vous dites si
j'ai pour qu'on découvre les coulisses
du cyclisme c'est une démarche purement
égoïste ton histoire de n'évacuer
quelque chose de faire la paix avec moi
même si on la présente d'une manière
psychanalytique c'est il ya deux phrases
de vous qui sont je vais pas les
interpréter je vous assure il ya deux
phrases de vous qui sont si j'avais lu
ce livre à 15 ans j'aurais jamais fait
de compet ça c'est une phrase de bien
j'ai bien fait du mal
et alors il ya une autre phrase de vous
qui 10 à 20 ans si on m'avait dit si tu
bois un litre de gasoil tu gagneras tour
de france j'en aurai boudeuse pour
gagner 2 ouais voilà deux phrases qui
skie qui s'opposent aujourd'hui c'est
quoi votre état d'esprit
mon état d'esprit par rapport au dopage
oui non pas par rapport au dopage par
rapport à ça assure d'un côté vous étiez
prêts à tout pour être champion et
l'autre côté en fait quand vous avez vu
ce que c'était champions vous avez envie
de le faire c'est ça comme ta phrase
vouloir vraiment c'est vouloir ce qu'on
ne veut pas voir a expliqué à
s'expliquer
pas rentrer là-dedans tortues ninja la
prévenue bon alors votre carrière
commence le 12 juillet 1984 dans votre
sphère pierre-henri menthéour gagné une
étape du tour de france alors vous avez
11 ans vous décidez de champion et elle
se termine par une double fracture du
poignet quand vous aviez de maillot
jaune dans le tour de l'avenir voilà
alors on va parler de vous en parler de
votre bouquin d'aller voir c'est moi
honnêtement alors sérieusement
j'étais scotché par ce bouquin parce que
j'en ai lu des trucs on en a eu un
bouquin rive droite aussi j'ai écrit un
bouquin sur la dope
mais qui est beaucoup moins grave que
comme elle était intéressant que nous
tiens alors ses valises de junkie
d'ailleurs c'est d'observer que celle de
jean pierre houdin qui sait des gens qui
sont des piqûres d'héroïne mais c'est un
livre de junkie c'est à dire qu'il ya à
la fois la drogue
enfin là c'est le dopage et spar est
omniprésent ouais et puis une espèce de
routine la drogue fait partie de la vie
quotidienne s'est adressé hier une des
exigences des finances drogue comme ça
il ya une espèce pas de bonne humeur on
prend ça avec un certaine ce qu'il faut
que tu saches seaway dans le sport en
particulier dans le cyclisme c'est
culturel le dopage
oui c'est à dire que c'est complètement
désacraliser voilà dès qu'ils publient
déculpabilisation collective
elle ne fait que satisfaire l'exigence
est un milieu john key qu'il shoote dans
des ensembles c'est normal attente était
gamin tu as un chemin initiatique pour y
arriver on tend doctrine déculpabilise
c'est normal je pose même pas la
question ça même pas l'impression de
tricher et à l'impression de te soigner
seulement la mémoire moi je suis
halluciné c'est ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure je suis halluciné que les
autres que tout d'un coup maintenant sa
phase 1 enfin je sais pas moi j'ai
depuis que je suis tout le monde je sais
que les mecs du co2 à moi j'ai du temps
c'était était bâchée page sur d'or tous
les temps dans le lait sur ton film
dérange quand tu te dis fais le sommet
du tour de france n'ont jamais se voir
en général sport en général oui oui car
beaucoup de pognon
l'arrivée massive de l'argent dans le
sport ça derrière titres aurifères
parler par exemple un jour vous êtes
vous arrêter entre deux arbres
petit ils appellent ça va ils appellent
ça une fléchette chapitre fléchettes
dans la preuve qu'ils envoient dans une
petite piqûre dans le film typique
heures dans les po lire part au tour
suivant mais c'est naturel tu te dis par
exemple
vous dites aussi que ils sont des
piqûres avec 2 euros pour le plaisir du
geste et sa télé truc qu'on le voit il
ya des mecs qui en sont à cette dérive
passage c'est aussi un plaisir des
participants des piqûres avec de l'eau
parce qu'ils n'ont rien d'autre
mais pour plaisir de la pic alors qu'un
gros bidon et non mais c'était c'est
incroyable ce bouquin je comprends que
tout le monde quelle heure il ya une
espèce de bonne humeur vous expliquez
vous allez expliquer ça veut dire avec
tonton et tintin pour lui d'aller j'ai
ri ri chez mémé kessel en place baillaud
explique bâton c'est le temps et dont le
taux est de rendre ces violences et
amine ça c'est la méthamphétamine bad je
croirai tant tintin c'est le père vite
un le rire il faut que je recommence
oui c'est là la ritaline les kamikazes
japonais prenez de la ritaline pour
s'écraser que sourire sur les haies sur
les porte-avions a salué la mémé c'est
l'âme et edwin donc si tu veux tu prends
ça t'a déjà goûté un petit peu il ya
longtemps et l'entente si tu prends un
cocktail là je veux dire tu es le plus
beau le plus fort le plus intelligent
caire ainsi bloquer l'entente qui la
parfaite vélo c'est vrai depuis que j'ai
lu ce bouquin je me dis le vélo
finalement alors bon
voilà voilà l'exemple même avec tonton
et tintin on est allé faire est riche et
d'aimer ça veut dire qu'on s'est envoyé
à peu près tout ce qui existe comme en
fait disent que le sport juste pour le
sport et ça avec ça c'est une autonomie
de combien parce qu'on valait faut quand
même faire une précision pendant le tour
de france ne font pas ça oui c'est
l'intérieur c'est le dopage c'est le
dopage bonne franquette l'étude c'est le
plaisir
celle ci est située à ça si je peux la
prendre une manière toxicomaniaque on
aime bien ça on aime bien ça est
d'accord c'est alors que comme tu fumes
un gros pétard ou tu vas te faire un
rail tu vas te dire bah oui mais il aime
ça mais non là c'est le petit dopage 36
à celle de pages sympa parce qu'on
arrivait à deux trucs c'est le dopage
issus du génie génétique c'est légal
il ya les allégories plus grave il ya
les corticoïdes bon ça on meurt pas les
en fait comme ça non non mais je n'avais
j'imagine que ça nourrit le muscle go ça
doit faire une série tkr lien émotionnel
façon il n'y a aucune raison pour
effacer ça fais pas tu fais avec le
sourire quoi ce truc est drôle c garcia
ce tu veux le dire hier pendant toute
l'émission puis là on parle de deauville
alors on a l'impression d'un seul coup
d'avoir un vélo entre les jambes
bon alors on continue
moi j'ai lu le bouquin et honnêtement
j'ai deux trois trucs que je voudrais
dire quand même dingue parce que c'est
vraiment fou on les corticoïdes bon les
corticoïdes cd il connaît la cortisone
on connaît il ya le pays ou alors le ps
a augmenté globules rouges dans le sang
ça améliore l'oxygénation du sang
et alors ce que j'ai lu dans ce bouquin
c'est incroyable ce que j'avais vu aux
guignols
quand il se foutait de la gueule de
virac mais je croyais pas que c'était
vrai c'est que les mecs ils sont
tellement ils ont pris ces trucs là que
la nuit ils sont obligés de faire des
pompes pour pas que le sens cohérent le
sas et on en a parlé s'il paraît que
c'est vraiment arrivé
mais depuis depuis sept huit ans on a
des données démontrent cardiaque c'était
très on hématocrite de donc depuis deux
ans fait agresser parce que dès lors
c'est ça le sport testeurs situe descend
en dessous de 25 du ca sion minutes
savez bip bip bip bip u13 et châtrés
vrai parce que l'augmentation dû rythme
car parce qu'ils sont obligés d'avoir
des anticoagulants et des va et vient
sur la table de nuit c'est fou cette
histoire alors il ya le pot belge
s'écoute et qu'on sait qu'on devient
belge il va dire je ne dis rien ne dit
rien parce que le pot belge faut pas
voir ce que dans le pot belge à ja je
dis je
amphétamines cocaïne héroïne antalgiques
vasodilatateur corticoïdes morphine et
ça vaut entre 500 et 2000 balles et les
mecs qui font du vélo il s'en voit ça
tous les faits mais pas comme michel
bruballa j'en ai rien les mecs arrêtez
je m'intéressais cinq minutes
moi je veux dire tu aurais pu faire un
livre dans le showbiz attention silence
on sniffe moi j'ai fait secret défense
moi je peux dire un truc c'est qu'à la
télé lui mais qui n'en sont pas là non
un virement
nous on ne savait pas si on en croit
explique ed en fait ouais on a découvert
ça quand il ya un petit malin qui a pris
5 l analyse et voilà on s'est dit [ __ ]
on a compris on sait faire retourner
complètement on prenait des en fait
parce que d'abord cette culture est ça
faisait partie de notre boulot tu vas
faire un critère que tu vas faire des
critériums pendant 30 jours après le
tour de france les mecs qui sont
défoncés il fait 30 jours ouais ouais
et en plus ils doivent conduire la nuit
un jour tu es à toulouse le lendemain tu
es à bordeaux le lendemain tu es à paris
tu vois bon on savait pas ça et puis
d'un seul coup on s'est rendu compte que
les mecs qu'ils ont récupérés - mettant
de la coke et de l'hérault pour rendre
les mecs accro je suis jeune je suis ce
que je sais c'est pas grave si tu lis je
suis coach me cyclisme au masculin
cyclisme féminin jeannie longo
quatre-vingt dix ans ils pédalent encore
il ya bien un truc alors on veut aller
vite parce que voilà il faut ajouter
bouquin après tout les gens au collège
des fois par exemple pour mes débloquant
tueur compte un directeur de course veux
pas que tu aies galles il tient à
injecter débloquant ce qui fait tout le
monde essaye de pédaler tu n'y arrives
pas corse et richard virenque c'est un
bêtabloquant alors les cobayes vous êtes
cobayes ont vu tout vous utilisent comme
cobayes avant avant même les animaux sur
un test des produits sûrs avant même d
avoir testé zico bas il y avait des
chevaux et cobayes ont des vélos et or
il ya un moment terrible
et les français de reprendre à poubelles
j'avais pas ça marche bien ce club est
bon c'est quand vous dites un truc sinon
je te paye quand j'étais petit bois six
mois puis c'est le pot du havre alors
non quand vous dites il mettait poussé
quelque chose qui ressemble à un droit
c'est bien ainsi qu'un hara c'est
vachement interpréter ce truc là non moi
j'avais une duration la scène qui s'est
enquis c'était quoi
une incroyable c'était tout et tout le
temps en train de frotter sur l'a7 au
niveau 80 et qu il avait donné un petit
kyste qui s'est enflammée puis c'est
devenu un truc comme ça c'est donc j'ai
dissocier contrat qui m'était pousser
quoi ouais mais c'est parce qu'on
m'avait foutu de la cortisone pour
draguer pour les slows ça doit être
génial
bon enfin voilà donc vous ce que vous
expliquez c'est malheureusement ce qu'on
comprend c'est à dire qu'avec eux la
télé les sponsors ben voilà on est
obligé de gagner sinon on les vire eh
oui jamais eu confiance elle vous dira
un sport est une course comme le tour de
france où les types vont essayer d'aller
le plus vite possible pour avoir un
maillot marqué crédit lyonnais
on apprend quand même que lino il a pris
la tête d'une grève contre les contrôles
de mon but c'était pas de ça et surtout
blessé heureusement c'est parce qu'à des
[ __ ] qui sont autour qui profite de
ce que génère le cyclisme ouais et
qu'ils vont jouer les parents dans 28
d'hellemmes que jalabert mais je connais
pas bien mais tout ça n'est pas bien de
fois tour de france bernard hinault 5 5
x jalabert vous dites qu'il avale le
vent tout comme d'autres avalent des
religieuses au café jalabert dans le
tour d'espagne par à gré une vache
espagnole qui a bouffé de l'herbe dans
un champ où il avait peas et elle a
gagné une étape
pioli le gagnant du djihad ansa
attention ça c'est un truc qui possède
en france soir et j'ai pas dis tout ce
qui était dit dans france soir
alors on m'a dit voilà que deux shows
lille en hémodialyse on m'a dit berzina
eu un cancer de la moelle épinière
c'était plusieurs mecs et le giro 95 on
m'a dit ça et on m'a dit est ce que
c'est des conséquences directes du
dopage
moi j'ai répondu oh mec a fait
l'interview jeudi à temps un mec qui
fume deux paquets de clopes par jour il
a plus de chance de choper un cancer des
poumons clamer qu'ils fument sinclair et
le lendemain on a dit que c'est moi qui
avais mis d'accord par greg g20 de
londres et qu'il avait été atteint après
avoir été le le vélo de myopathie
mitochondrial non il en a eu une autre
côté officiel mais c'est pas moi qui va
ce que vous dîtes surtout c'est qu'un
jeune gars qui va mourir en direct c'est
peut-être ce qu'ils attendent pour
comprendre qui est vraiment un problème
de fond aujourd'hui c'est un problème
s'inscrit dans une logique qui dépasse
le cadre du cyclisme du sport c'est un
problème de santé publique
parce que quelqu'un avait été voir mon
pote à l'hôpital ouais parce que là on
peut rigoler un peu se font dorer en
vendée alors moi je rigole d'avancé
rigole heureusement qu'on rigole parce
que le fait qu'il soit ce que ces
réunions mais si on avait été voir mon
pote l'un qui faisait 40 kg alors que
j'étais un playboy dessous de 76 kg 1
beaucoup les uns belle gueule bronze et
les yeux bleus l'aurait vu sur lit
d'hôpital voilà ça donne à réfléchir
bien sûr lorsque vous dites alors ce cas
pas du tout rassurant dans votre bouquin
et roanne c'est que c'est pareil dans
tous les sports un jour été léchée inde
au tollé en italie
et là vous dites les amateurs de records
part abandonné leurs illusions parce que
vous avez vu des gens de tous les sports
et même vous dites qu'en dehors du sport
les gens qui prennent la france est le
plus grand consommateur manga qui quand
même francky lisant tout l'algérie à
gragnague rap rozak etc
il viendra c'est pour être meilleur
gratuit
interview d'accord
et c'est vrai dans tous les sports en
judo on a eu djamel bouras ray qui est
venu dire que finalement été innocenté
alors c'est un peu compliqué quand même
à savoir qui dit la vérité
vieira lui dit qu'il est innocent et
revivra que vous ne soutenez vachement
avoir vous êtes très près le discours
est le suivant oui aujourd'hui j'ai une
question à poser aux médias un point où
est ce qu'on demande à un richard
virenque d'état d'intellectuels pour qu
est-ce qui devrait endosser la
responsabilité de tous le dopage qui a
dans le sport pourquoi est ce que
richard qui a été un empereur du sport
français
voyez une vivante manier en france oui
il ya des gens de descendre de son
piédestal tous ses concurrents directs
dans donc sur leurs deux oreilles
est-ce que ça encourage les autres mecs
a parlé oui non et voilà alors le nom
richard virenque tout le monde se fout
de sa gueule moi c'est super riches à
son boulot c'est d'être coureur cycliste
professionnel et je crois qu'ils
s'expriment bien sur un vélo pour lui
demander d'être un intellectuel oui bon
match a bien alors chantez vous raconter
que d'arriver dans une boîte et vous
chantez au nestier vous savez le
champion nestea ouais je chantais ne
tient pas selon amnesty
et si vous chantez
certes il n'y a pas de partie civile
vous ne serez pas en tarte et à
l'orientation et la gueule sur le cas
alors je précise que moi je suis surtout
en train de travailler avec richard
crever s'occuper les un très très bon
m
[Musique]
je vais
m
les vieux le futur os humains et just
the way you lie et joyce irish toby sur
un tube
hu
si seulement
oui moi et des rémois qui avait nos
chances
la styrie mai
et tant mieux
on a beau bien sorti même talent
alors tu veux
grâce à la chanson oui il arrivera à
faire ce qui me gêne avec su faire en
vélo 33 tours
en tous les cas on est terminée
avant d'inviter nos deux invités
suivants vous avez déclaré
maintenant que j'ai arrêté le vélo ce
qui me fera le plus drôle c'est plus moi
j'ai les jambes dans la chanson peux
seulement dire dans la chanson on peut
semer rasé aussi sur oued en mairie la
plaque ils font ouais et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de nos latitudes
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux